while the military maneuvers in belarus
are in full swing and as you can
probably see behind my back there is a
tank column that is rolling towards its
firing positions now elsewhere on this
training ground which is by the way
located next to the belarus polish
border we're going to see aviation
motorized infantry units paratroopers so
all in all this is going to be a pretty
intense and action-packed day both for
russia's and belarus's military now this
is a combat readiness test of a joint
russian battle russian task force the
military say their main goal here is to
see how quickly they can deploy combat
units in belarus and secure key
infrastructure as well as belarus's land
border and airspace it's reported that
12 russian su-35 fighter jets along with
a number of air defense complexes
including s-400 triumph have been sent
to belarus from russia to support these
extra sizes
now the number of troops involved
doesn't require the two countries to
notify other nations that russian
defense minister sergey shoigu however
russia did let everyone know including
nato members about the exercises in
advance as a gesture of good will
[Music]
now the most active part of the
exercises between russia and belarus is
expected from february 10 to february
20th that's when drills are going to be
held across five training facilities and
four air bases in belarus punctuating
the message of the united front of
moscow and minsk
in troubling times
you